Kylie Jenner admits she's happier after  splitting from ex Tyga I'm having so  much fun I've had more fun this past  month than I have in like years on the  next episode of life of Kylie the  20-year old reality star gets slammed  for the 2017 Met Gala and dishes on how  much her life has changed since being  back on the market  she and Tyga split just before the big  fashion bash now looks like I feel like  I could be more myself I feel way more  free and I'm just like really genuinely  happy right now  we also get a glimpse of the beauty guru  choosing which Versace gown she wants to  wear to the gala  as if rocking seven thousand crystals  wasn't enough bling to turn heads Kylie  has another request after picking her  final red carpet look this is really  loose it needs to be like this like  where my body looks crazy like I need to  kind of suffocate